hey guys it's Joanna here it's two
really early in the morning and I'm just
out in the park so today we'll be doing
a 15 minute beginner boot can workout I
know many of you have been requesting
for workout videos which do not require
any jumping so that's what we'll be
doing this workout it's going to be
intense enough for you to be burning fat
burn lots of calories but there will be
no jumping involved so we'll start with
a 5 minute cardio which will also act as
a warm-up then move on to four minutes
of lower body three minutes of core two
minutes of upper body and we'll finish
with one minute of plank okay so each
workout will be for 40 seconds with 20
seconds rest in between remember to
listen to your body
take this workout at your own pace and
keep progressing each time you do this
workout so get your body ready you can
do this workout at the comfort of your
own home or you can do this workout at
the park nearby so let's work out
together so guys let's start watching on
the spot okay remember to take this
workout at your own pace when you feel
like you need to take a short break and
breathe do that and get back into the
workout when you're ready alright so I'm
going to set my timer okay and we'll
start with your warmup and also cardio
so the first warm up is going to be lake
curls okay so I just want you to Korea
Lake and just open and close your elbows
okay your arms very nice and easy good
so we'll do this for 40 seconds just to
get your heart rate pumping just to get
your blood flowing and your muscles
warmed up good and remember to keep your
arms high so do not drop your arms keep
them high in front of your face and just
curl your leg and get your legs warmed
up and working good very nice keep going
Lake curl step side to side good
okay really stretch and open up the
chest and keep your body nice and open
good few more seconds good 20 seconds
rest okay so the second workout second
warm-up will be shuffle to touchdown so
I just wanted to shuffle and touch down
okay so shuffle to the side and touch
down
that's it so let's start in the center
shuffle and touch okay let's go start
shuffle touch so touch good go low and
squat shuffle and touch very nice one
step to the left one step to the right
touch look straight ahead
open up your chest do not hunch and do
not keep your body all the way down okay
so open up a chest
look straight ahead give me a nice big
smile and just touch side to side
good you should feel like twerking you
should be a hot air pumping and it
should make you feel really good good
rest
third warm up it's going to be a low
squat and I want you to imagine you're
drawing a square so start now move
forward and move back okay keep a low
position at all time so forward and step
back okay let's go you really you will
really feel this let's guess step
forward back nice stay low and back
let's start with our right leg first
back nice go say low and back
one more a let's switch to lapis good
stay low keep your arms forward and just
place them in the center back you know
it's like you're walking like a crab
really say hello
few more nice right now back to right
back
few more low oh my god I can feel my
thighs too warmed up I can feel them
burning and shake it out okay next it's
going to be half burpees to sprint so
just get into a burpee come up and just
sprint three times down again
burpees up and sprint okay really like
jock let's go out in up jock good out in
and just jock nice out in jock jump and
jock nice oh there you go if you want to
you can also choose to March okay out in
jock very good keep going run out in
March if you want to and one last one
jock give me one more and jock good job
and the last cardio will be groaners so
all I wanted to do is get into this
position and just bring your left leg
forward
back and right leg okay so it's just a
nice
stretch good let's go look at our and
stretch very nice bring your heart rate
down slightly before you get into four
minutes of lower body arch look up
stretch good open up the hips open up
the inner thighs and just stretch whoa
can you feel your heart rate
can you feel muscles good that's what we
want and remember to just breathe and
good come up shake it out a little bit
now let's move on to lower body so the
first workout is going to be forward and
back lunch okay and we want to be
starting with our right leg right so
take a white step forward touch in the
middle take a step back touch okay well
what is that let's go it's just a stone
good cut in the middle forward lunch
touch back go as low as you can okay but
make sure that your knee do not rest on
the floor good down touch forward touch
so you should really feel your leg
working your bum working and this will
really help to tone those lies and also
burn those excess fat
and shake it off slightly I'm just gonna
kick that away same workout now on our
left leg okay take a breather
ten seconds I need to catch my breath
within and out okay check it out start
in the middle left leg now ready let's
go forward down oops
touch down touch forward touch back good
so if you want to keep your balance
look straight ahead and look at one
behind okay touch forward lunge and
touch good back keep it steady
if this is only you know like your first
few times doing this kind of workout
just listen to your body you know make
sure that you're doing proper form don't
rush the workout it's more important
that you get the workout right there
rushing through it and not feel the
right muscles good now shake it out good
second little body workout will be squat
so I want you to get into a nice deep
squat and then just kick to the side
okay right so frontal view will be squat
and just alternate kick to the side okay
you will really feel on your outer
thighs as well let's go start with our
right leg open kick good nice deep squat
kick down again with every squat they
take you want to keep your chest open
and upright and face forward nice down a
duck good down kick to the side okay
high kick do not give me a low kick I
want to see those high kicks to the side
good job keep going up nice breathe last
two more up one more good job last
nobody workout we want to be working on
our inner thighs now this is my favorite
you have probably seen me doing this two
minutes
so stand wide toes pointed out okay get
low into a sumo squat position
stay here and all I want you to do is
lift your heels on the floor and every
time you leave lift your use of the
floor you should figure inner thighs
working and squeezing okay if you don't
feel like you can take a step slightly
wider you should really be shaking your
legs should start feeling really saw
this small movement it's going to really
kill your legs and give it a nice good
workout for your inner thighs working up
heels up nice keep going stay low not
now do not come up now stay low whoa I
am absolutely sweating and dripping and
one last one oh my gosh up and shake it
out so now grab your yoga mat we want to
get into a full body crunch okay right
so lie down on the floor and what we
want to be doing is just okay I'm via a
side crunch foo in X 10 good
so crunch elbows in nice in extend nice
so we're now moving on to core workout
crunch in and out you're halfway there
guys you're doing really well
in and out good these are those
co-working feel those ABS working keep
going all the way in all the way out low
enough to not arch your back in and I'll
get whoa up down slowly don't rush the
workout be sure they're getting proper
form good and now turn the other way
face down your core muscles also involve
your back muscle okay your lower back so
now we want to be working on that face
down what I want to do is down Superman
with a back squeeze okay squeeze your
back right at the top let's go
up squeeze good extent and down up
squeeze for your low back do your upper
back working and really squeeze and feel
and engage those muscles nice no I am
gripping I'm sweating and you shoot as
well few more down and up
oh my god what a good way to start your
morning
absolutely dripping one more and down
good and I'll just push yourself up we
want to get into mountain climber okay
so I'm just gonna adjust my med slightly
with mountain climber all you have to do
is place your arms hands on the floor
legs up and just imagine you're climbing
the mountain okay so remember take care
your own pace you can go fast if you
want to if you are still an absolute
beginner then go slow you know feel your
abs working to your upper body working
supporting your weight and keep your
weight at the center of your body and
the center of gravity this is a really
good core workout really good cardio and
really good fat burning workout okay so
take it slow and easy and as you find it
that you want to put yourself pick up
the pace good keep going guys oh you can
hear my love breathing nice few more
Oh oh my god ah rest it out rest it out
now on to upper body so we want to start
with push-up okay I believe that
everybody should know how to do a proper
push up and should be doing push-up
because it is one of the best upper body
workout so on your knees bring your butt
down okay straight body go down and up
that's it it is as simple as that so
your body should be in one line not to
this if you do this this is wrong okay
so make sure you're not doing this make
sure your body is not sticking in the
air but it should be one line that's in
your core and you should just go down
and up and push and usage has and your
shoulders muscles good and get those car
nice slow down up fast
good so check your position check which
part you're feeling and rich muscles
you're engaging one more very nice oh
now we want to move on to plank up down
okay second let's work out hang in there
with me
let's do this together so in high plank
position
okay we just want to go down and up okay
if this is difficult beginners everybody
needs a starting point starting your
knees so down okay and up down and up
so alternate your hands and up and
eventually get into your toes down and
up good down and up so what you want to
aim for is minimal movements on your
hips okay so what you really want to be
engaging is your core muscles good down
and up oh my god I am absolutely sweaty
dripping but I know this is gonna be
doing me a lot of good okay down and up
last few more one more up and now just
let it out
that's 14 minutes of workout find a
workout will be plank okay one last
workout right
we'll be playing let's do this together
and now let's get into a pie position
and just hold it here alright we'll do
this together try to hold it for one
minute if you can you know breathe and
just really and get your coat again with
plank why you don't want to be doing is
dropping your lower back this is not a
plank or doing this this is not a plank
as well like any Co workout and get your
car your car involves the front part of
your body your abs and the back part of
your low back so engage both muscles and
just hold it here good job guys
you're more than halfway there three
more seconds two more now let's hold it
for another 20 final seconds keep going
I am dripping I can see my sweat but
that's really good because I know I've
worked hard enough ten more seconds hang
in there with me don't drop now hang in
there let's count down together five
four three two one awesome job oh my god
I've got sweat
take a breather you've done so well
wasn't guys ah I am still catching my
breath
I am absolutely drenched in sweat oh my
god but I'm feeling so good and I know
this is a great way to start my morning
or even end my day okay so guys if this
is only your first or second time doing
this video then follow the pace of this
video but if you've done this video many
times and you find that it is getting
too easy for you then what you can do is
increase the workout time to 45 seconds
or 50 seconds and decrease the rest time
to 15 or 10 seconds okay and don't just
do one set you know this is one set what
you can do is challenge yourself to at
least two or three sets then you will
have a full 30 to 45 minutes of solid
workout so do this workout at least
three to four times weekly for best
results and I can assure you in four to
six weeks time you will decrease in body
fat you will feel really good you will
feel energized and you will see the
difference not just on the outside but
also on the inside so if you like this
workout be sure to share with your
friends
do this workout together with your
workout buddy as well all the best